yesterday president joe biden spoke to
the nation again about the situation in
russia and ukraine with vladimir putin
invading ukraine on the premise that hey
we've got to keep the peace in these
independent regions that i've recognized
as independent even though they're in
another country and we already talked
yesterday about why that entire framing
doesn't make any sense it violates a
number of different international
protocols
but the latest is well what is joe biden
going to do
and joe biden is in a politically
difficult situation because no matter
what he does the right is going to
criticize him the right is criticizing
joe biden so let's go back
first
the right attacked biden when it came to
russia
saying we should want to be friends with
russia we should we don't want conflict
with russia we don't want war with
russia fine okay uh but insisting that
biden would be too harsh on russia
whereas trump was more friendly and open
yeah we know
then very quickly the right shifted to
saying trump would have been would have
been harsher with russia so putin never
would have tried this if trump was still
president biden is being too weak with
russia
but then at the same time they're sort
of defending what vladimir putin is
doing saying yeah you know
putin seems to be going to places where
they want him in ukraine we'll get to
that later and kind of defending what
vladimir putin is doing and at the same
time they are saying well the sanctions
that biden is putting on russia
are not nearly strict enough so they
want all sides of this i want to just
speak clearly to you
joe biden has put in place some
sanctions and we're going to talk about
those here is biden yesterday making it
clear
that this is an invasion by vladimir
putin take a look last few months we've
coordinated closely with our nato allies
and partners in europe and around the
world to prepare that response
we've settled along and i've told putin
to his face some month a month more than
a month ago that we would act together
and the moment russia moved against
ukraine
russia has now undeniably moved against
ukraine by declaring these independent
states
so today i'm announcing the first
tranche of sanctions to impose cost on
russia in response to their actions
yesterday
these have been closely coordinated with
our allies and partners and will
continue to escalate sanctions if russia
escalates
we're implementing full blocking
sanctions
on two large russian financial
institutions
veb
and their military bank we're
implementing comprehensive sanctions on
russian sovereign debt
that means we've cut off russia's
government
from western financing it can no longer
raise money from the west and cannot
trade in its new debt on our markets or
european markets either
starting tomorrow and continuing in the
days ahead we'll also impose sanctions
on russia's elites and their family
members
they share in the corrupt gains of the
kremlin policies and should share in the
pain as well
and because of russia's actions we've
worked with germany to ensure nordstrom
2
will not as i promised will not move
forward
as russia contemplates its next move we
have our next move prepared as well
russia will pay an even steeper price if
it continues its aggression including
additional sanctions okay and then joe
biden uh going on to say that
even what he has done so far is not the
full scope of what he is willing to do
take a look
this is the beginning of a russian
invasion of ukraine as he indicated and
asked permission to be able to do from
his duma
so let's begin to uh so i i'm going to
begin to impose sanctions and response
far beyond the steps we and our allies
and partners implemented in 2014
and if russia goes further with this
invasion we stand prepared to go further
as with sanctions so the big discussion
the serious discussion you know all
these
right-wing gutter people that are just
going to criticize biden no matter what
he does i'm not really interested in
engaging with them let's let's engage
with a serious criticism which is
are these sanctions going far enough
and despite repeating that the u.s won't
send troops to ukraine
is the u.s basically fighting this as a
proxy war so let's take these two
questions one by one first of all
are the sanctions put in place by the
united states
that strict and the answer is sort of
but not really one of the real concerns
about the very first set of sanctions
was you're really just sanctioning the
regions that putin invaded
you're not really hitting russians and
russia directly now with the sanctioning
of russian banks
and more russian billionaires and their
families and their assets and ability to
move assets you are
more directly hitting russia proper
but you could go a lot further why isn't
biden doing it well you'd have to ask
him why he's not doing it
but it makes sense that you've got to
keep something off the you've got to
keep something on the table rather
in case putin goes further because there
is speculation at this point and so far
most of the speculation has been borne
out to be accurate in in terms of what
putin has done so far there's
speculation that putin's ambitions are
greater than the dunets and luhansk
regions that so far he has sent troops
to
if putin wants to push further into
ukraine up to and including the
ukrainian capital kiev and wants to try
to affect regime change installing a
puppet government who knows what putin's
ambitions are
you need to leave something more on the
table geopolitically and from a foreign
relations standpoint it makes sense you
don't do everything yet
because you suspect putin has not done
everything yet so
we are getting to harsher sanctions
and and it is logical to not go fully
out because you've got to be able to
bring down more if and when vladimir
putin pushes further into ukraine now on
the proxy war question
i think we just have to accept at this
time that the u.s is waging a proxy war
against russia now sometimes by proxy
war we mean both parties are using
proxies in this case it is russia
pushing into ukraine
and the u.s using
nato
sanctions
and arming of ukraine and supporting
ukraine as a proxy to fighting russia
directly and proxy wars are not
objectively good or bad but we have to
recognize that while joe biden has said
we're not going to put boots on the
ground um we're not drunk we're not
using drones
and at least um
for the time being we're not doing cyber
attacks on russia
we are engaged in a sort of war here and
that is not an endorsement or a
criticism but it is a reality and that
is something that we're going to discuss
more on tomorrow's program
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when i use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say i'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card privacy will autofill a
virtual card number and then after
signing up i can delete that virtual
card so i know i'm not going to be
charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone
but i left my wallet somewhere i don't
have my real credit card on me i can use
a virtual card on my privacy mobile app
but really the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft
privacy is a totally free service and
you'll get five bucks to spend when you
go to privacy dot com slash pacman the
link is right underneath this video